everything is all right now
everything is definitely all right now
that casey musgraves has announced her
fourth studio album star-crossed will
arrive friday september 10th the
texas-born country star's forthcoming
project follows the massive success of
her 2018 lp golden hour which of course
catapulted her into super stardom after
taking home four of her six career
grammys including statues for album of
the year and best country album well
we'll have to wait a few more days to
hear the project in its entirety here's
everything we know about star-crossed so
far
it would have been extremely awkward if
i just like
you know acted like this last chapter
like didn't happen for me so yeah i
think
you saw my my highlight reel
with golden hour and this is the other
side of that as casey revealed to apple
music zane lowe her divorce to fellow
musician rusty kelly is definitely at
the forefront of the new project which
was written and recorded in the
aftermath of their separation now the
pair were married for nearly three years
and called it quits in the midst of the
global health crisis back in 2020 casey
originally teased the new project to
rolling stone in early 2021 instead of
their marriage it just simply didn't
work out it's nothing more than that
it's two people who love each other so
much but for so many reasons it just
didn't work i mean seasons change our
season changed and during that change
the singer used music as therapy telling
rolling stone
i can't help but to write about what i'm
going through i want to honor the huge
range of emotion that i felt over this
past year past six months i also want to
honor the relationship we had and the
love we have for each other because it's
very real and as always casey's album
will make you feel something you didn't
even know was possible using the title
track to discuss her divorce i signed
the papers yesterday
[Music]
i feel like so many people can relate to
that moment and if that song doesn't hit
you in the fields i'm not sure what will
now the new album sees casey reuniting
with her golden hour producers daniel
tashian and ian fitchuk and in the
extensive rolling stone piece the trio
painted a diverse portrait of the album
with casey explaining looking at the
list of songs we have some that venture
into like a bill withers land we've got
that synth stuff that we always love and
we've got some eagles or america
territory there's a little bit of a
dance box
[Music]
and in the june july issue of owl
magazine casey confirmed the project
would include 15 tracks sharing this new
album that i'm getting ready to put out
is very very personal to me i had a lot
of fun exploring myself and my emotions
in some different ways than i have
before so i'm excited to share those and
casey definitely kept fans on their toes
finally sharing the album announcement
on social media on august 23rd in
addition the space cowboy singer also
released a trailer for a film starring
herself which will accompany the album
and stream on paramount plus on
september 10th
[Music]
the 50-minute visual will also feature
cameos by eugene levy drag race winner
simone princess nokia victoria pedretti
and meg stalter and more recently casey
gave fans another glimpse of the new
album sharing a second song titled
justified along with the accompanying
music video which sees her driving along
an open road crying as she remembers a
past lover
[Applause]
that alone just gets me so excited to
hear the rest now casey recently shared
a snippet of the 15 songs on social
media and told apple music zayn low she
describes the project as a modern
tragedy in three acts which definitely
comes through after looking at the track
list so there appears to be some
nostalgic and sad songs towards the
beginning with if this was a movie and
simple times but towards the end things
appear to be looking up on songs like
what doesn't kill me and there is a
light so what songs are you most excited
to hear on star crossed let us know in
the comments below